I mean there was so much speculation
there was so much rumor there was
obviously the documentaries that had
happened before but we tried to and away
apply science to it you know i mean if
in the original trial that the boys had
in 1994 if they had been able to afford
forensic expertise if they'd been able
to afford DNA which in a way in 1994 was
very much in it some in its infancy
anyway if they had the resources to do
that i don't think the conviction
whatever have occurred you know we don't
have a sense of closure we have to keep
doing this we have to keep asking people
you know please watch this documentary
please read the books please research
the case because that's the only way
we're ever going to have that sense of
closure and that's the way we look at
this you know if we ever want to be
exonerated if we want the people who
belong in prison in prison and for the
authorities who did this to us to be
held responsible it's sort of like a
necessary evil that you had to go
through even though it's not entirely
pleasant all the time I was looking for
the truth in that there was a horrible
injustice that was that needed to be
righted and I was trying to I just
wanted to find out why this happened how
in the world could something like this
happen if they didn't do this why would
somebody why would this ever have gone
this far it's so kind of unbelievable so
most people who had seen Paradise Lost
would contact me Pearl Jam Eddie Vetter
from Pearl Jam got involved in 1999 and
Johnny Depp same thing in 1999 they had
seen the film but no one really knew
what to do with the case it was and we
heard elite you know we were hiring a
legal team and trying to work on an
appeal and we made a donation to to the
Defense Fund and Laurie wrote back wrote
to us and that was really the beginning
of an unlikely friendship
and and as as that friendship developed
so so did our understanding and
knowledge of the case and that became a
vortex that you disappeared into I think
anyone who who engages with the case
sort of goes down that that rabbit hole
because it's extraordinarily it's
fascinating it's incredible and it's
it's it's extraordinary an extraordinary
story and and horrifying horrifying that
it that it that it was still in fact you
know unfolding and and we wanted to do
what we could to assist I mean yeah
there was financial help but there was
also just an amazing knowledge and I
don't know where it comes from but she's
she just pulled everything together and
from that point on it just is it you
know I don't know how they did it they
were making films they were in the
middle of King Kong they they made
lovely bones they made all these films
and still managed to get Damien out of
prison so yeah you've always said we
always tell everyone this case is
nothing out of the ordinary this happens
all the time the only thing that made
ours different was that we were
fortunate enough to have cameras in the
courtroom that caught it on film there
are lots of people who aren't that lucky
you have people in Arkansas right now
you know people think that just because
you come up with DNA evidence or just
because people admit they lied on the
stand or just because new witness has
come forth people have this impression
that oh the case is over then he's going
to get out they're going to overturn it
and that's not true I mean that's only
fifty percent of the fight you can have
all the evidence in the world pointing
towards your innocence and they will
still kill you and sweep it under the
rug so that they don't have to admit
they made a mistake the other half of
the battle is getting word out to the
public letting people know what's going
on there were so many lies that we're
told in that courtroom and nothing made
any sense and then there were all these
people that actually were never even
in to testify like the alibi witnesses
it's just shocking you know how Damian
was on the phone that night and you know
he wasn't anywhere near the crime scene
and those people were actually
interviewed by the police and nobody was
even called in every single time people
watch this movie every single person
that sees this is a potential jury
member that can make sure the same thing
doesn't happen to someone else so for us
it's also bigger than just this case and
it was something that became emotional
for us I mean it became a friendship and
then it became something that we were
devoted to but certainly it was Fran and
Laurie that drove this I always tell
people Peters beyond a doubt the
smartest human being I've ever
encountered in my life but he can also
be a little crazy at times you know he
would do things like I've just been out
of prison for a month I'm in a state of
extreme shock and he thought it would be
great to go paragliding so he really
straps a parachute on me and off the
side of the cliff we go and you know
it's always odd to doing talks like this
people always say you know you always
seem so calm and Zen and like that's
because you never saw the video of me
crying and screaming the whole time I'm
you know going off the cliff